hi i'm simon biles four-time olympic
gold medalist and today i'm going to be
playing with puppies while answering fan
questions
oh my god they're like puppy puppies
come here come here
probably ice skating or diving
they ran away i think someone peed on me
for me the goals i've set outside of
gymnastics would be helping the foster
care community and kids
my diet is pretty simple a lot of
proteins fish
chicken vegetables and then outside of
gym
my cheat meal would be pizza
the hardest part about being a gymnast
is probably training like seven to eight
hours a day
just practicing conditioning rehab
six days a week and then i have sundays
off oh okay
okay go to your friends
[Music]
typical morning get up wash my face
brush my teeth do any of that shannon
against
i don't really have face care routines
nothing too crazy
probably a couple months before it's
like really really good it depends on
what event what it is
hi i know i see you i see you
if there's usa gymnastics group chat i'm
not in it i don't know i don't get my
number
a lot but we had one at worlds and we
talked about
food a lot and memes hi baby
are you up here
definitely me probably
probably about a hundred and my favorite
is probably some from my collection that
i have where are you guys
going probably some from my collection
no specific ones that are kind of all my
favorite
you look like you want to come home with
me
listen to music and it kind of depends
on
the vibe right now probably something
with the baby
unfortunately i have not because we are
very busy all of us
but if they ever want to go to lunch or
something i'm in houston
outside of gymnastics i don't really
have too many hobbies i like to just
rot because i'm just tired sometimes but
i do like to shop
i'm good at that hanging out with my
friends and family
hi where do you want to be on my lap
usually take a hot bath with like epsom
salts
relax watch a movie or netflix
right now on netflix i'm watching shit's
creep
come here yeah
tastes like hard metal but it feels nice
and it looks good
right it's just hard metal
hey guys thanks for providing the
puppies from paw works
and check out the link in the video say
hi i want to get adopted
please adopt me and me somebody i need a
home
you